well I became the first candidate to put  forward a comprehensive immigration plan  and we saw those images watching that  image of Voskhod and his daughter Bella  dia is heartbreaking  it should also piss us all off if I were  president today and it should spur us to  action if I were president today I would  sign an executive order that would get  rid of Trump's zero tolerance policy the  remain in Mexico policy and the metering  policy this metering policy is basically  what prompted both Scott and valaria to  make that risky swim across the river  they had been playing games with people  who were coming and trying to seek  asylum at our ports of entry Wallace got  in Valletta went to a port of entry and  then they were denied the ability to  make it asylum claim so they got  frustrated and they tried to cross the  river and they died because of that on  day one they want